is a three-day weekend you know you
think about sales and family barbecues
the unofficial end of summer
today's holiday holds a much deeper
meaning our kenneth charles joining us
from a local labor group with the labor
of love that has led to for many a
labor-less day candace good morning
good morning except for us heather of
course we're always here for you guys
now at the time that this three-day now
weekend was formed labor unions were
fighting for a number of improvements to
working conditions including that good
old eight hour work day we all enjoy now
this was amongst many of the topics
discussed at the two events in new york
in the 1870s according to the u.s
department of labor a convention and
parade took place at the start of
september but many workers were unable
to attend because they were scheduled to
work well in rebellious fashion they did
anyway sparking employers to give the
day off it wasn't until june 28 1984
that congress passed an act naming the
first monday of september the legal
holiday we all know now as labor day
those holidays off those break times um
those celebrations are because men and
women fought for those rights that we
have um to be able to celebrate this day
your family is protected by many laws
that pass you know like i talked about
the 40-hour work workweek you know you
get overtime you know we now have social
security there are the worker
protections so you know while we get to
enjoy this lovely day it's almost the
last day of summer so to speak um
understand that we get that because of
the hard work that the people have done
ahead of us
so enjoy but you guys the work's not
done
that's what i hear both the afl and sdiu
tell me there are a number of labor
rights concerns advocates are fighting
for today coming up i'll tell you more
about those concerns right now i'm live
outside the ciu local chapter off of
west sahara and north rancho i'm kandace
charles it's news now